well i'd say the very first seed of
avatar was a dream i had when i was in
college i was 19
and i had a dream about a an amazing
forest that was
bioluminescent and i got up afterwards i
was so inspired by the dream i started
sketching it in
oil pastel colored pencils and so on a
lot of people ask me
you know what's the best advice to
someone who wants to be a director
and the answer i give is very simple be
a director
pick up a camera shoot something put
your name on it as director
now you're a director i think it to sum
it up
very succinctly it's make it accessible
get the audience over that hump of
watching a period film
where people dress differently and they
speak differently and it all happened 85
years ago and who cares
and there's only one way to do that
which is through characters through
characters that you really love and care
about
and you know we fall in love with jack
and rose as they fall in love
with each other i you know the thing
that got me into filmmaking was
the love of that sense of
otherworldliness that a film can create
in your
mind
[Music]
a lot of people ask me you know what's
the best advice
to someone who wants to be a director
and the answer i give is very simple
be a director pick up a camera shoot
something no matter how small no matter
how cheesy no matter whether your
friends and your sister star in it put
your name on it as director
now you're a director everything after
that you're just negotiating your budget
and your
and your fee so it's a state of mind
is really the point once you once you
commit yourself to do it
then the hard part starts which is that
you have to forswear
all other paths because you can't keep a
foot
in cabinet making and a foot in
directing you can't keep a foot in
one job and it's it's a total and
all-consuming thing and i suspect that
many
of the difficult and challenging things
in the world whether it's research or
whatever but certainly in the arts
must be all-consuming because you're in
competition with people who have made
that
decision who have committed themselves
100
you're competing for resources you know
it's just it's a big coral reef
and uh it's a big food chain and you're
competing for resources
and you're competing against people who
have made that commitment if you don't
make the same commitment you're not
going to compete
it's that simple what's the objective of
the story i mean
i'm fascinated by the titanic and
everything real that happened but you
have another obligation you have an
obligation
to go beyond that and bring people in to
see
i think to sum it up very succinctly
it's
make it accessible somehow make titanic
accessible
not that it's inaccessible in a way but
but get us
get the audience over that hump of
watching a period film
where people dress differently and they
speak differently and it all happened 85
years ago and who cares
get them in get them involved
subjectively in the event
and there's only one way to do that
which is through characters through
characters that you really love
and and care about and you know we fall
in love with jack and rose as they fall
in love
with each other you know up on the
screen and then
there's a certain point where we realize
we're on the ship with them
you know i'm talking about as an
audience experientially you know in
the watching of the film and i think
that you can't do that in a docudrama
format where you have a multiplicity of
characters and
you do them all perfect historical
justice we very very carefully observed
the history
and carefully observed the the detail of
the of the physicality of the film
you know creating the sets and so on but
but ultimately
it's it's an experience it's an
emotional experience it's a love story
it's
you know if uh to use one of my favorite
films as as a teenager uh david leans
film dr zhivago it's not really about
the russian revolution it's really about
these people in this event that's
greater than them
and i think titanic my film titanic is
is the same thing well that's what great
novelists do from
tolstoy whoever you wanted to write
about right you borrow energy
from the from the chosen setting and in
some way i think that energy is returned
as well because
by being subjectively involved through
this love story
i think you have a more emotional
appreciation of the event
itself when did you first conceive of
the idea of avatar
what was your inspiration um
well i'd say the very first seed of
avatar was a dream i had when i was in
college
i was 19 and i had a dream about a
an amazing forest that was
bioluminescent
and i got up afterwards i was so
inspired by the dream i started
sketching it in
oil pastel colored pencils and so on and
years later
i started to incorporate that concept
into a story it wasn't avatar it was
another story
and then years after that in let's see
95 i i was
looking to tell a story that took place
on another planet
that i could develop my newly founded
visual effects facility called digital
domain
and so i incorporated it i
incorporated that concept into a thing i
called avatar
so you know in terms of inspiration
there was that there was
every piece of nature photography i've
ever seen every moment that i've spent
in a forest up in canada where i grew up
catching
you know frogs and snakes and that sort
of thing just
you know wanting to be kind of one with
the forest which i did naturally as a as
a kid i loved it
um my time underwater you know as a
scuba diver
hundreds of hours all over the world
seeing amazing colors and reef fish and
and various animals that got those
colors and those
creatures got incorporated into some of
the plants and animals of pandora just
made them really big
as opposed to the little tiny ones you'd
see on a reef
so the inspiration came from really all
over the place my whole life
it also came from my sense of a strong
sense of outrage and injustice about
what was happening to the natural world
what was happening to
indigenous cultures around the world
what had happened to them historically
during the colonial period my concern
about the state of the world and
the state of nature and of our sort of
cultural disconnect from nature
so you know there were a lot of things i
wanted to say with the film
and you know you feed that all you melt
that all down in one big pot and you
stir it
what comes out is avatar when did this
movie
first occur to you when did you know you
were going to do it
it was five years ago i i had um
you know been been studying titanic the
history of it a little bit and i've been
following the
you know the discovery of the shipwreck
and all that and i just sort of got this
idea to do
a love story set on titanic with the
wrap around you know the book end
of the uh of the shipwreck and i
literally sat down to make some notes on
this for the first time
and the next day i got in the mail an
invitation that was a black
card that said in red letters titanica
and it was an invitation to
uh a friend of mine was the the
underwater photographer on the abyss and
he had done a special on the making of
the imax film
and so i went to see that and i saw
these two russian submarines and i said
i can use those you know as the great
opportunist i i said i can use those i
can go to titanic
and so uh the next day or within a few
days we were on a plane to moscow to go
make the deal for the submarines and
and then it took a while to actually get
the film started i actually made true
lies in the in the meantime
but it's been three solid years for me
uh working on this picture
you made 12 dives to the site
of what now is the burial ground of the
thai town right
right i didn't think i could outdo alien
for pure shock
i don't think anybody could you know it
certainly has been tried a great number
of times and
no nobody's really done it i mean going
into a movie theater on opening night
not knowing what to expect the mystery
the wonder and then the sudden shock and
terror that that film created you can't
beat that so i had to come up with
i had to come up with an end run around
that that would be equally entertaining
for an audience but in a different way
and i knew i could do action i knew i
could do white knuckle
action that i could i could turn the
screw tighter and tighter
in an action sequence so i figured all
right let's do that let's jump
off from the from the horror premise
into what ultimately becomes an action
film
you know i don't think ridley liked the
fact that i came along and kind of you
know trampled around
in in his little world that that he'd
created and and
now as a filmmaker having made the term
two terminator films then seeing others
work in the same sandbox i know what
that what that feels like
the notion that you make magic so that
people come in
to the theater and they get an
experience beyond
uh what they might otherwise have yeah
tell me what you set out to do
well you know it's interesting you say
that because
when i think of what it was like for me
in my
sort of formative years you know as a
teenager kind of
figuring out what the world was all
about you know going to films
and seeing and getting taken through
that doorway into another world whether
it was science fiction or the past or
just some other place some other people
you know and i i think of what that
meant to me at that time and i think
so many people in hollywood i don't mean
to dis hollywood in any way but they
they've lost touch with that sense of
transport you know an almost religious
transport that a movie is supposed to
have um and i'm not saying that all
films
need need to do this but i you know the
thing that got me into filmmaking was
the love of that sense of
otherworldliness that a film can create
in your
mind and in your emotional place that
you cannot
exactly you know out of your daily life
into some place or some feeling
sometimes it's not another place it's
another emotional place
i was hired to direct a film called
piranha 2. i was hired by a very
unscrupulous producer who worked out of
out of italy
and he and i he put me with an italian
crew who spoke no english even though i
was
assured that they would all speak
english and i actually had to learn some
some italian very quickly and i'm
talking about in two weeks because
that's all the prep time i had because i
was actually replacing someone else
and i was put into an untenable uh
situation and then
and then fired several couple weeks into
the into the shoot and and the producer
took over directing
and it turns out that he had actually
done that twice before on his two
previous films and that was his modus
operandi
in order to get the financing and then
ask the director
and in the course of of throwing me off
the movie he never showed me a foot of
the film that i had shot
he he held on to the dailies he wouldn't
we were shooting in jamaica and he would
i would shoot in jamaica the dailies
would go to new york be processed he'd
fly to new york and look at them and not
send them back
for me to see so i wasn't even seeing my
own film so he
you know he basically came in and said
your stuff doesn't work
doesn't cut together it's a pile of junk
and you're off the movie
and then he took over the film and i
thought you know i really don't
i mean okay maybe maybe i'm just bad
maybe i'm just not good
so i went to um you know a couple of
months later i went to rome
to find out sort of the truth like what
what really happened
and he wouldn't show me any of the film
and i had been in rome prepping the film
for a couple of weeks before we went and
i remembered the code to get in and so
um i went in and i just ran the film for
myself
and it wasn't that bad because all i
wanted to know was just one simple
fact could i or could i not do this job
and so and i made a few changes you know
before i flew back which i don't know if
they ever caught i don't know if the
editor ever noticed that i actually
fixed a couple things
but uh but you know i had to
i had to know whether whether what they
had said was true so here's a case where
everyone around me
had basically said you stink you suck
you don't know what you're doing
and i just and i accepted it but then
a little voice kept saying i don't think
so i don't think it could be that bad i
remember doing some pretty cool stuff
with the actors in this moment in that
moment
and i looked at it and it was fine so
then i thought you know what i actually
can do this and i just fell in with a
pack of you know thieves and wackos here
and
but i also realized that i was gonna
have to get busy and
create my own thing that nobody would
hire me after that experience nobody
would hire me and just put me on a film
i'd have to create my own thing
and hang on tenaciously to that in order
to be able to direct again and that's
why i wrote
the terminator and i had many many
people trying to buy that script but i
wouldn't sell them
i wouldn't sell the script to them
unless i went with it as the director
and of course that was a turn off for
almost everybody
but we did find one low-budget producer
who was willing to make the film
and that was john daly at hemdale and
that's how i got
my real start how do you get to be the
director
i mean where do you come from how do you
do that where'd you grow up i went
straight from being a truck driver to
being a film director
is it true what happened yeah no kidding
exactly all you've got to do is stand
there and say i'm the director
did you go to film school or something
no no nothing no well what i used to do
is i'd uh
i was working as a truck driver on the
weekends i drive down to usc i live in
los angeles right i lived in orange
county at the time a truck driver yeah i
was truck driver
i'd drive down to usc i'd go in and for
the cost of the xeroxing
i would xerox all these like doctoral
dissertations on
optical printing and film stock film
emulsions and all that stuff
build up these big binders of like how
everything was like a total gearhead
so i gave myself like a full college
education for
about 120 dollars wow so you're saying
your whole
while you were a truck driver yeah you
were just fascinated with sort of uh how
they did special effects and that kind
of stuff but it was a hobby for you
yeah it was a hobby you never dreamt of
being a filmmaker oh no i i was starting
to get serious about it i just hadn't
busted a move yet because and how old
were you at this point when you were
being tried
24 25 really i was married lived in a
little house and he was like
you're a regular guy i was a regular
regular guy
so you're telling me you're driving a
truck
how do you make the transition to be the
director of how do you get on a set
and was your first movie terminator 1 uh
i got i got hired to do this film called
piranha 2 and they fired me after 10
days
and what did you get hired to do
directed directed yeah piranha 2.
rana 2 yeah the absolutely the best
flying piranha film ever made was it a
jaws rip-off
yeah absolutely never give up because
it's going to be
unbelievably hard it's going to be a
ridiculously brutal
uphill fight all the time and you just
have to have
tremendous stamina and and
self-confidence to to power through it
um you have to not listen to the
naysayers
because there will be many and often
they'll be much more
qualified than you and cause you to sort
of doubt yourself
but you know what i learned from those
early days was to trust
trust my instincts and to uh
to not back off um because
when the hour gets dark your instinct is
to
or your your tendency might be to say
well this is just too hard and nope
you know nobody should have to go
through this in order to accomplish x
whether it's a movie or
or whatever but to to in
in the pursuit of excellence and i think
you can be in the pursuit of excellence
when you're working on a low budget
science fiction horror film if it's how
you define it
um you have to go all the way first rule
is you can't do it all yourself
even though you may know how to do many
of these different tasks you physically
can't do it
and you need you need a team and you
need the respect and the trust of that
tell me about the difficulties of making
the movie
uh and and the financing and sacrifices
you had to make to get it
on the air and what your determination
was
that'll be a mouthful tell me about that
um
how do you go about making this kind of
movie now that you've got your story set
now you've got your character set now
you've got your actors set now you got
to make a movie
well it all starts with the pitch right
so i so i go in and i sit down at 20th
century fox and i say okay guys
here's the picture all right it takes
place in 1912.
uh it's a period drama uh we can't have
any stars because they're the characters
are too young
and uh it's probably going to cost north
of 100 million dollars
and everybody dies at the end and
there's no sequel no sequel possibility
what do you think sound good and they're
like let us think about this yeah no
it's it's difficult so you told him
right up front we're talking about more
than one
three-hour movie more than 100 and if
you make a three-hour movie that means
that it can't be played but so many
times in a theater and they're not
thrilled about that
exactly plus you know you can't have a
toy line sprung out of it you can't have
indefinite number of sequels theme park
attraction is right out
you know you go in but you don't come
out
[Laughter]
but you know so it's a it's a tougher
sell it goes against the grain of
hollywood wisdom to do a picture on this
scale
uh at in that in that budget range
without all of those things that give
them comfort so what did they say
let us see this james cameron go well
yeah there was a bit of that and i have
a little deal with them anyway i have a
relationship with them and they trust me
and we've gone into precarious places
before and come out of it looking good
so
you know they they it held them back
that one step and they said let me write
the script i'll show you that so then
they read the script and they're
they're literate people they could see
it on the page they could run the
picture in their head
and they said you know what we really
hate it that we like this so much
because now we're going to have to make
it
you